عندما أنظر إلى النظام البيئي في الوقت
الحالي لجميع الشركات المشاركة في
السيارات ذاتية القيادة ، أرى الكثير من
الشراكات كثيرًا حتى أنني
أجرؤ على تسميتكم يا رفاق منحلون ،
هل تحاولون فقط الشراكة مع
كل شخص يمكنك الآن.  يعني
أنك تشارك مع Domino's على
سبيل المثال ، فقط قل مهلاً ، دعنا
نحاول ونفعل كل ما في وسعنا ونرى ما الذي
يلتصق
جيدًا بتطور كائن
السيارة والنظام الذي يعمل فيه
يعني أنك بحاجة إلى الكثير من الشراكات
للشراء في الطبيعة المفتوحة ، هذا في
الواقع نظام مفتوح لن يكون مملوكًا
لشركة Forge ، لقد قمنا باستثمارات أولية مبكرة
خاصة حقًا في
هذا المجال لإنشاء القدرة ولكن
هؤلاء الشركاء يريدون ربحًا
والاستفادة من هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة  أعني أن
هذا لا يشبه أي وقت في التاريخ
صموئيل حيث ستغير هذه التكنولوجيا
نموذج العمل ، لذا فأنت تتحدث عن
نموذج أعمال أرى هذه السيارة
خلفك مباشرةً وهي في شراكة
مع دومينوز بيتزا  الشراكة
معهم لأنك قلق من أن
الناس لن يشتروا سيارات
للأفراد وكذلك سيارة دومينوز بيتزا فورد
التي تعمل حوالي 24 ساعة في اليوم ، لذا فهذه
هي نوع الشراكات التي تحتاج إلى
بناءها لتحل محل شخص عادي مثل جو
أشتري السيارة جيدًا عندما ذهبنا إلى
Domino's Patrick Doyle ، لقد قام بالفعل
بعمل هائل مع تلك الشركة ، إنها
حقًا شركة تقنية في حد ذاتها وليست
شركة بيتزا ووجدنا هذه
الحقيقة المثيرة للاهتمام في العالم التناظري ،
البيتزا موجودة في سيارة يقودها  من قبل
الناس ونعلم مدى ضخامة هذا
العدد الذي يمكنهم من مراقبة ذلك
وقلنا ماذا لو استخدمنا قدرات روبوتية ،
فما الذي يمكن أن نقدمه الآن للعملاء
لم نتمكن من الحصول عليه من قبل ،
فالفرص غير عادية حقًا
لذلك اختفت Ford و Domino  إلى
المرحلة التالية من هذا الأمر
والإعلان في الأسواق الأخرى عن
الأفكار الكبيرة التي لدينا معًا ، لدينا
هذه الأفكار الرائعة التي تعرفها
اكتشفنا أن الأشخاص يفضلون حقًا الحصول
على البيتزا الخاصة بهم  من السيارة بدلاً من
شخص ما تم تسليمه لهم حتى الأشخاص الذين
يعيشون في مبانٍ شاهقة كانوا
يبنون السلالم ، نعم ما وجدوه
أنهم يفضلون النزول ولا
يضطرون إلى ارتداء أحذيتهم لأنهم
لا يشعرون بأنك تعلم
أنهم يتحدثون مع شخص ما لا
يعرفون السيارة التي لا يهتمون
بها ، ولا يتعين عليهم التفاعل معها
بخلاف قول أعطني البيتزا